(audience cheering)
Hello, hello, hello, hello
Hi Julian,
how are you?
I'm good thank you,
It's really early in the morning, so,
yeah that's good.
Soldiering on.
(laughing)
Well let's get you back in bed right after this.
I am so excited though,
to talk to you about Godzilla versus Kong,
because I grew up watching both of them
so it was about time that they co-star together.
And speaking of co-stars,
Millie Bobby Brown is your co-star in this,
and everybody is crazy for her.
But, I heard that you guys had to recite
Shakespeare together for a screen test,
is this true?
Yeah, so, I remember,
we did a chemistry read, we went into this office,
they're like,
"hey we want you to read this script."
I'm like okay it's probably from the film,
and then I look at it,
and I'm like,
this looks like it was written
300 years ago,
by a 60-year old dude,
I don't know what this is.
And it ended up being Romeo and Juliet,
so it was an experience.
But the story obviously goes well
because you get the part and now you're in the movie.
Mm.
Now I heard that you recently celebrated not one,
but two big milestones?
Yes, yes I just turned 18.
(audience gasps)
Well not just, but I turned 18 like three months ago,
but I just moved out of home.
I am currently, yeah,
I'm chilling in my own space,
I'm independent, I'm living life.
So.
Well I have a quick question for you.
I wanted to play a really quick game with you.
Before we go to the break,
I was wondering if we could kick it up a notch?
And this is called Before The Break.
(dramatic music)
Alright, now we see tons of fighting between
Godzilla and Kong in the movie,
but we were thinking like,
I would love to get your take on who would fare better
in these everyday situations.
You tell me who would reign supreme
and do better at everyday situations,
like let's say, Julian,
attending a dinner party.
Godzilla or Kong?
I feel like it would be Godzilla because,
he would just have better table manners.
He could also like, flambé,
and like, or flambé,
or like, do a banana's fosters or some crepes
with his fire mouth.
(audience laughing)
Yeah he could just be cooking the food.
He could make the food
and bring it to the dinner table.
Exactly!
Who would spare better in speaking to the manager.
I feel like Kong, because he can actually talk.
I feel like Godzilla would just yell at him,
so Kong.
Babysitting?
Babysitting, mmm...
Godzilla. Because I feel like,
I used to get babysat by my older cousin,
and I hated it because she was angry
quite a lot of the time,
but it really did kick me and my brother into shape,
so,
probably Godzilla.
Meeting the parents.
I feel like Kong,
because Kong could actually shake the father's hand.
'Cos he has hands.
(audience laughing)
Yeah.
Okay, what about being broken up with?
Kong.
Godzilla would do like,
something revengeful.
Like go to their house and burn every single
person they love,
to the ground.
Alright which one would you pick
to star in a romantic comedy?
Godzilla, that'd be fun.
And why is that?
Can you imagine?
Well, I'm pretty sure Godzilla vs Kong
is a romantic comedy to be honest,
if you watch it in a certain way.
It's a bromance, comedy film,
that's what I'd describe it as.
Then see the bromance of the decade,
Godzilla versus Kong.
Julian Dennison,
I am so happy to make your acquaintance.
It was an absolute pleasure.
Alright now get back in bed!
Godzilla versus Kong is in theaters
today,
and on HBO Max!
(cheerful music)